at Google cloud we give you a variety of
ways to learn
we understand that some learn best from
our hands-on labs or through self-paced
video courses on sites like Coursera and
Pluralsight while some prefer to learn
directly from Google authorized
instructors or even a combination of all
three methods when it comes to
instructor-led training it's not always
easy to get a group of people physically
together but did you know that you can
get all the benefits of an in-person
classroom training without the hassle of
travel we call this a virtual instructor
led training with Google cloud virtual
instructor led training our certified
instructors use the same curriculum as
our in-person training they will take
you through the same demonstrations and
run the same hands-on activities as they
would if you were in the same room
together the instructor and students
connect via webcam developing a sense of
community like a traditional classroom
this creates an engaging environment to
answer questions and aid in supporting
students individually to make things fun
we use interactive tools like quizzes
polls and even games in the virtual
classroom flexibility is paramount
students can join from different
locations across multiple time zones our
customers rave about our virtual
instructor led training with one
organization we ran 17 unique virtual
classes for four hundred nine employees
across four different time zones
they gave the overall experience on
ninety-eight percent satisfaction rating
virtual instructor led training offered
the same in-person experience with a
certified trainer but at a scale and a
schedule logistically difficult to
achieve otherwise Google Cloud virtual
instructor led training czar open and
ready for enrollment you can check out
our classroom schedule on cloud Google
comm forge / training forge - courses or
reach out to your Google representative
for more information we eagerly await
the opportunity to e meet you face to
face in our virtual classroom hope to
see you there
you